thank you so much for meeting with us
i'm just so excited to hear your story
thank you first of all an alien
abduction it's an interdimensional
contact
it's been an incredibly life-changing
experience
can can i hear a bit about it
yes of course my very first experience
happened when i was uh five years old in
my bedroom playing and uh
a very brilliant bright light came into
the room
through the railings of my window
i had missing time from that about 8 p.m
till about 11 p.m in the night
[Music]
so we've got actually a same-sex couple
the name is sarah and jan all of a
sudden jan is standing there and she
can't breathe and two hours have gone by
then i had another major experience at
the age of 16 i became pregnant without
being
sexually active
and when i went to the doctor the doctor
found that i had ovarian cysts of a
woman that would have had several
pregnancies or miscarriages
wow wow
this is a an x-ray of the ovarian cysts
you know the entire scarring in the womb
is what's interesting
it looks like somebody that already had
had many many pregnancies oh wow
i also had cysts at like 15. so wow i
did to where i had to i actually had to
get on birth control and i wasn't
sexually active that's what they told me
as well
i'm starting to think that maybe
it wasn't an astral projection that i
had but
that maybe i had
an objection
situation as well
i'm starting to think that maybe
it wasn't an astral projection that i
had but
that maybe i had
an abduction situation as well
[Music]
you don't know how many women i talk to
that have the exact same thing
and
i'm not here to tell you what to believe
but there would be these times where i
would become pregnant and then have
miscarriages
even when i wasn't partnered
wow
so i started to see these kinds of
patterns that would happen every so
often but of course i wouldn't connect
it to any kind of
odd phenomena the doctors would say it's
a blighted ovum
or you're stressed out or maybe you just
want to have children so much that you
you know create these pregnancies and
hormones and balances in the body it
wasn't until 2013
that i had an actual conscious
experience
where i physically was taken out of my
bedroom onboard craft by these grays and
introduced to my hybrid children
wow
[Music]
what i was hearing from her was so out
there that i didn't know how to wrap my
head around it but at the same time
i am not one to talk okay
i've told people that i have been sucked
out of my bedroom and hovering over the
planet so i have to honor that truth
just like the people around me have
honored mine
it was these little eight white lights
that expand before me and these four
children emerged and the first one was
very frail looking very thin skin gray
colored skin
incredibly large eyes of the pupil the
size of our ocular socket so massive
wow
very complex pigmentation to the iris
yeah and so
i almost want to say it's like colors
that we don't necessarily have okay or
eyes or just in general in general wow
yeah the colors that they utilize it's
like a completely different spectrum
than ours almost like iridescent
sounds like your house it sounds like my
house
so there were you have four you said
there were eight lights and there were
four children or yeah so there are eight
in this particular hybridization program
i've been a part of four different
hybridization programs
[Music]
[Music]
you